the main result of this research
is that people who drink a lot
1830 lives per month
binge frequently
in those people to a capacity of the
brain of the brain
to consume so much that it is increased
increased in relation to people who
drink little
acetate is the  acid found in
vinegar
when drinking alcohol enemy 2 then
converts the alcohol into acetate in a
process that starts within a few
minutes as I say 2 produces more than
you can use to consume
was transshipment to the blood
through the blood  in this touch it
circulates through the body
and the whole body and the brain the brain the
brain metabolizes acetate
the possible damages of
the consumption of the state in the brain
are 3
in the short term we know that the consumption of
acetate in the liver is pro-inflammatory
promotes inflammation and people
in people who live long
the book accumulates fat
can lead to insulin resistance
and over time  me can even cause
liver failure well how the
brain metabolizes acetate it
can also in the brain also cause
inflammation
that is something we need to investigate
another record of the consumption of accepting something
is
and for a dream
now imagine a person who spends one
day two days  without being
insufficiently fed
and after
not eating this person I had to
drink
which can cause
a drop in blood glucose in that person
and as
the brain almost completely consumes
glucose
the energy
feels can feel a lack
When alcohol is consumed,
the body has acetate and the brain
will learn that the exact acetate and
next to promoting provides energy,
the person will not be aware of being
aware of the process but will
learn that they can feel much better
after  consuming alcohol another danger of
consuming acetate in the brain is that
the process of oxidizing acetate generates  was
adenosine
is a chemical substance
promoting a feeling of slow solo in
people
are the relative substances
and since a heavy drinker
has twice the capacity in the brain
to consume each acetate, he
is probably producing more
adenosine than a person who drinks little
the brain will adapt to that in the
nation of adenosine
in those who become
dependent,
you will get used to the presence of
elevated adenosine and when you
stop drinking when you resolve you want to
stay sober
you will go through the symptoms and  withdrawal symptoms
but acetate can continue to be elevated
up to 24 hours after the last
drink
and then
loss of alcohol
and adenosine is also felt soon
our results
have something like this
imply the following implications
for alcohol detoxification
when a person stops  from drinking from
drinking alcohol
first you feel the lack of alcohol but
after some time you feel  We also theorize the lack
of action,
there is the possibility that
acetate can
be a treatment for the
different detoxifications,
nothing is going to make
the detoxification process really easy, but
if we press yes, we can facilitate it
and make it less unpleasant,
perhaps it is a high treatment,
I do not suggest that  patients go on to drink
liters of vinegar to detoxify but
this idea is something we are going to do we
intend to investigate
something like this using acetate
and if we see a benefit of acetate
for detoxification
we need to find a safe
and secure and economical
practical way
of giving it to patients
Yo